hello
hello
good morning
or afternoon
or evening
whatever the
whatever time it is for you
hi
hey hi hello
dude mrd why are you just typing periods
in chat before we start
just putting punctuation marks
in the chat
why are you doing this
it's a good night
ah it's 10 30 in the morning for me
time zones are weird
hold on making sure i got everything
okay
okay
okay
hello isaac
by lorenzo
ace
lmao
hello
okay we were trying to get in the dlc
last night right or yesterday
now
um we have to go somewhere before that
now right yeah
are you doing the early dlc i don't know
yet uh we have to go somewhere before we
can even go there so we need the doll
of some kind
i want to get another from software game
what would you recommend any of them
they're all
good they are all good so how do i you
said it was at some uh
like a school or something not a school
i don't remember where to get the doll
yeah duke's archive where is that
bunk
funk
getting a feel for it i don't know where
duke's archive is
anor londo bonfire to the left i bet
uh boom
the dolls for the painting
okay then we need to get both of those
things
you can't even light this anymore
because i killed the fire keeper
man i miss old in orlando it was pretty
now it's all dark and scary
am i going the right way
why is chad on the right i moved it hey
it's smoke
smoke
the chain's in it's a mimic
we know the secret
oh another hull bird though
okay that chain's out
got it
oh i need those i need another twinkle
tit
excellent
excellent
streaming earlier than usual
uh i'm streaming earlier than yesterday
and then i streamed earlier than this
two days ago
so i don't know what the frick you're
talking about bro
very elden ring vibes right here
hello
sealed by the great lord's power
okay
so i can't go in there
we need broken pendant
i need a lot of stuff don't i
you killed the hydra yup
we did kill the hydra
you need to place the lord vessel you
guys told me not to place the lord
vessel
i always thought you stream around noon
i mean there's different time zones
as well
thanks muji i'm glad you liked it
oh also i can't warp out god bless
america
i'm boning
let's boner back out of here oh wait we
can't because this will just take me
back to right here won't it
oh my god
this area stinks
gotta go back down here again
at least i think it'll take me back to
that one
i don't want to waste a boner though
i'm unstoppable
you have to kill a boss
i think we just have to place the lord
vessel
i did for i forgot that as well
all right that's all the way down
excellent
now i have to go this way this is kind
of kind of bad like this this glitch is
i guess i killed the fire keeper so it's
my fault that i have to do this right
well she attacked me
so
life goes on
bonk
yes all streams are avod after the
stream is over charles
absolutely it's so dark
now we need to do something before that
mrd
we gotta go to duke's archive to even
access that area
i was gonna place place the lord vessel
but chat told me not to
now we have to do this
uh get cuphead
cuphead's awesome
okay fall off buddy okay
not gonna have your body knock me off
the edge this time
there we go
excellent
excellent
[Music]
don't just call it fake information you
probably just forgot
fake info
reddit
i ain't gonna cat i hate reddit that
website is just awful
yeah i know i'm not going to
the painted world yet i'm just trying to
get to a bonfire so i can warp out of
anor londo
what up ludwig
[Music]
thanks spyros
wait can i access now i just go over
there okay perfect
i wish there was one here
reddit is bad absolutely
why is everyone on reddit so angry i
don't know that is an excellent question
they're mad about everything like every
little thing you can think of they are
mad about that
i just opened this now i have to go
around
i did kill the golden golem
i'm actually going to
ban you because you just seem really
annoying okay
that that mrd guy was just typing
periods in chat before we started and
i'm i just don't like that like you're
just gone i'm sorry
you're just saying stuff that's wrong
and we've already talked about and
you're spamming punctuation marks before
we start i ain't about that
bye bye
watch you play dark souls 1 reminds me
of my playthrough
i mean i would hope so
you did the fire keeper quest line
yeah everyone in chat wanted me to kill
uh
big chest
so i did
not everybody but most people are like
kill kill big chest
she's a liar
so i did now we're here and everything's
dark and scary
okay
where where do we need to go
as we're saying uh
i already forgot
the fat ring is opie it's true we have
the fat ring
yep firelink's probably a good call good
call
you play dark souls 2 yes
yep
[Music]
for dlc i i don't know i'm i just i'm
just going wherever you guys want me to
you know but we gotta go place the lord
vessel that's what we want
hey take me down yonder sir
i am pleased to see you well
is it something urgent
what
why would i feed him these things what
do i get for it
i can warp here too
very well
then
stay still for a moment okay that's how
i get taken down
yeah we're gonna we're gonna do as much
as we can in one play through spyros
you get souls okay i don't want to do
that then
there's so much moaning in this game by
your own character
okay
place lord vessel
that's a big bowl dude
but yeah i plan to do these
play-throughs for all the souls games
anyone knows how i can get my hands on a
ps5
i'd appreciate it
damn that was sick
where's that entrance okay we know where
that one is
yeah how is that giant ass bowl in my
inventory
i don't even know all three of those
i can rest here
okay
offer souls to lord vessel why would i
do that
okay and this is how you get to uh our
boy yup
got it understood
can i walk around this area
no
not at all
okay take me up very well
as kingseeker i shall now instruct you
the lord's successor in your next task
to achieve your fate
fill the vessel with powerful souls
scarce few possess such brilliant souls
grave lord nito
the witch of izalith
the four kings of new londo oh the four
kings
of gwyn's souls and
lord gwyn's former confidant
seath
the scaleless
all the consoles are required to satiate
the lord vessel
hi crimson
are you ready
then we shall return
stay still for a moment
so it's just like elden ring
or no
elden ring is just like dark souls
excuse me
you have to go get
the powerful souls to unlock and mend
the elden ring
like the same thing i was lucky to get
my hands on ps5 when i could i don't
know how like seems impossible
to uh oh hello
oh you're the pyromancer i saved well i
see you made it out i did yeah i made it
out safely too i didn't ask i have my
pyromancy the great swamp so
i can use humanity to be a bit of care
oh yeah
by the way uh i can share my spells with
you i think you have a knack for it all
you need are the materials okay i'll be
pleased to help you
ah and
unless you find the magic's unsavory
unsavory
oh really
oh that's what he was [ __ ] asking me
no it's your choice i'm on the fringe
yeah i know
i'm dead or not that's who i am
i only wished that i could have repaid
you somehow
yeah why is it in elden ring that you
only need two does that make any sense
why do you only need two to uh
mend the elven ring
it would make someone sense that you
would need all of them
but maybe they wanted to make it like
super accessible
okay guys
where are we going
should we go to the catacombs
or
to the four kings
you seen moog sex dialogue no
there's a secret about from you have to
jump from the elevator halfway to get
there
hmm
okay
shards of elden ring these four lord
souls are conceptual
four kings
[Music]
catacombs let's see
you only have to level up the glove to
use the pyromancies
means go to asylum
oh god
i'm confused at where all of this is
actually
okay
i am gonna go wherever i want
bear
i don't know where that is okay
i'm gonna go down here
i don't have another one of those
[Music]
fight radon
wrong game sir
sounds fair i would hope so that the
streamer can do what he wishes
i do ask you guys a lot of questions
though so
let's go down here
yeah it doesn't really matter where we
go does it like we just have to get all
of them
and we have the best weapon in the
freaking game so we're good
wait what about these ghosty boys though
over here
that guy's in a barrel what a nerd
whoops
why is he all
crusty oh this is what helps with that
don't don't i use these and i can
actually attack the ghosts
[Music]
temper temporary curse allows engagement
with ghosts perfect
okay
how convenient
yes it's the rivers of blood
and i just use it now
[ __ ] it dude
it's getting through this area
oh yeah
oh yeah
this is just nice
i remember first time i was here i got
really confused this is where i needed
to
go it's a freaking maze
who are you gonna call
ghostbusters
you love baby
nice swing idiot there we go
can you do your best bari impression
you i'm afraid are maidenless
lol w in the chat
i thought i preemptively rolled because
i thought there'd be a ghost
hey what's this
saw that coming
you i'm afraid
are maidens
there's the chester chest
there's a chest over there
yes this is dark souls remastered
uh actually it's dark souls uh we
increased the fps that's what it's
called
whoa ladies
that's big souls
that's big souls right there
basically elden ring
wait where am i being attacked
this weapon is actually just stupidly
overpowered i love it
can i one hand it now i can
i can use a shelled
do i gotta jump that that seems scary oh
ah
i can't move
holy [ __ ]
wow their reach is incredible
i'm just scared now
i'm scared
i'm not as scared now
[Music]
i'm still a little scared
any ghosts
why is this one weird
this is a problem in here guys
i don't like any of that
nope
run
yeah why does my character sound like
they're about to finish
jesus
come on come come come come
why are there so many
leave me alone
no you can't jump
okay
that looks so jumpable right there
though
to get down there
you for real
okay
fine with this
that ain't gonna reach that ain't gonna
reach i need you a little bit closer
excellent
what up miro how are you
[Music]
i believe a lot of people die here i can
see that
nice
a very odd ladder
there's a staircase okay
that hurt
is this the guy oh no he's an npc
i'm out ghost
all right what up dog got any ghosties
well this is a surprise no kidding you
get a few visitors
say for ghosts
you have
the lord vessels
very damn right i do i know exactly what
your intentions are
you seek the four kings who might have
that's over this is the key
oh thank you the four king of slumber in
the deepest chamber of the ruins
use this key to break the ceiling
and open the floodgates
oh and do not forget the dark wraiths
are resolved terrible oh i'm sorry dark
void called the abyss
but the abyss is no place for ordinary
mortals although
long ago
the knight artorias traversed the abyss
artorias
okay
hello there the key to the seal is
nothing
oh have curse broken am i cursed
ooh
yeah give me one of those
okay bye
rescue him okay
i shall
i don't know what a stag is
sorry
what's that oh i'm not
i don't have the thingy on
please leave me be
oh
in bloodborne he's a spider
okay that's patches not whoever that is
a deer with antlers
so a deer
well i'm sorry
that's stinky
i'm just trying to get out of here fam
you know how you know you know i'm just
trying to get out of here
hatches is a spider
green tit shard excellent
what's a green tit shard
yeah we definitely didn't need to jump
that feels that's a major shortcut
though to not have to go through that
dumb area
fire in a
bottle troop
oh yeah this is the four kings yeah
okay
i use that guy's thingy excellent
cool
morning esther
i think once we beat this we just go in
order right
like if we beat when we beat dark souls
we just go dark souls uh two
bloodborne
dark souls three
sakura
this is the black halberd
black knight halberd
it's very strong
that back up
can i get a bonfire uh somewhere near
here oh it's these guys
okay
should i go that way and get in rest at
that bonfire
i'm scared now
yep
that's what we're doing
sweet
you have twitch no i don't like twitch
i streamed on twitch for four years and
i don't like it
it's a bad flap
all right
you don't like money
dude i wait i make way more [ __ ]
money on here than i do on twitch
it's not even close
if you want to donate you can do that
here it's linked in the description the
same way you would on twitch
okay see now we're just over here
and we don't have to go through the
ghosty town again
we
okay new bondo
just a whole bunch of dead people
excellent
al
they're following me this is bad
dude
all right i'm killing the dragons
i'm murdering them
hey trey what's up
killing the dragons from now on
usually i just run past them because i
thought once you go past the door they
don't really mess with you anymore
uh if you like did you like eldon ring
because if you did then dark souls 3 is
awesome
i died to a dragon
how do you get your stream in 1440p
uh i said it 1440p
hey youtube chat layout though either at
the full screen or small
yeah that's why i put chat on the screen
because i
i feel that
remember when i said i'm gonna kill the
dragons
free
okay maybe i'm not
[Applause]
maybe i'm not going to kill the dragons
because that's just white
i got a plan i got a plan
i'm just gonna keep running
like away
you see
see ya
look at us go
break all that up break all that up
spiritual success
ah i love it
yes
i've never beaten dark souls 2 so i'm
i'm actually a little excited to play
that
i will i
yeah i i kind of say this every day but
elden ring the more i play it the more i
dislike it
first time i play through it it's
freaking awesome
i think the late the the in game though
is
quite bad
like quite bad
the early game is awesome
yeah maybe except for the right at the
beginning i don't like very much
oh
okay how many of them are there in here
is it scary
i've played dark souls 2 i just never
beat it
ew
what the [ __ ] is that thing
what
hello
you're dead now
don't get me wrong i love elden ring
like elden ring is such a great game
but
there's clearly a lot of issues with it
am i doing damage
yes
yes
can the dark scary souls
skulls go away please
okay that's one way to get rid of those
i hear another one
what are you doing hiding in here
i'm not even talking about ellen rings
pvp
it's clearly like the pvp in all of
these games is clearly not uh
a
major thought
you know like they they don't care that
much
if they did they wouldn't have let all
of these unbalances go for so long
like it's been four months
so
if they were gonna fix it they would
have
what do dark souls fans dislike about
elden ring uh i don't like the end game
i think the end game is
awfully unbalanced
like really like it just spikes in
difficulty out of nowhere like you feel
like you're doing good and then it's it
just feels like a bunch of unfinished
areas
with spikes in difficulty that don't
make any sense
it doesn't flow very well
in the end game
i still love the game it's great
like uh people saying that elden ring is
a bad like anyone saying eldon rings a
bad game is just
that's silly
but it's definitely not perfect
needs to create an npc with moderate
skill and can act as a summon no co-op
makes some bosses really difficult
um
i think i get what you're saying
i think co-op
like
summons and elden ring trivialize
everything
like even the late game
you another one of these guys
dude this area is
scary
not gonna have any thingies
oh estes
okay
honey
nice
people that love diablo immortal yeah
the pay to win
yeah no kidding
the thing i like to know the ring in
game was malakap's boss fight yo mal the
boss fights are cool everything
surrounding it's kind of [ __ ]
my daughter couldn't find me for a week
i was yeah you're fighting melania yeah
understandable understandable
we all were
what
i saw myself roll just saying
now we're gonna have to get out of here
all right
let me swing thank you
things are gross
nope
i'm getting a lot of rooney boys here
but i don't know i don't have any more
estes
yeah it has issues but it's still an
amazing game yep
i can see why people have stopped
playing it though
like
it's taxing it it's a lot you know
here's a great metaphor for elden ring
okay i told this to
to meddle the other day
think of elden ring as just a massive
massive penis right like it's just so
awesome
and it's what everyone aspires to be
and it looks great
but sometimes you just don't want the
big dick
because it's just too much
right too much going on there that you
just don't want it
right now
you'll come back to it every now and
then but do you want it all the time no
because that just hurts
it's a very odd
analogy for this but
i think it fits it
perfectly
you can use humanities to heal
yeah
yeah i'm gonna die to the four kings
here aren't i
i really am
yeah that yeah the burnout
true
the burnout dude
you need the ring to fight the four
kings by the way you can't do the four
kinks
what the [ __ ] i mean you know what i'm
talking about
don't jump you need sif oh man
all right i'm gonna have to bone her out
huh
why don't you guys tell me before i went
all this way
you guys get what i'm saying
you understand the analogy
i don't want to see what happens i
warned you before i didn't see it
i missed it hang it
you didn't read my messages i can't read
every single message people calm down
oh man
all right we gotta go back
all they said is get the ring
so no idea what that means right
but we're gonna say words
that's fine we're fine
had to boner out of there okay where do
we go for sif
wait i needed those didn't i
because we gotta buy the seal from andre
right
we
i haven't taken many dicks i'm not
saying you have to take the dick i'm
just saying
it just makes sense
sometimes you don't want the big kahuna
all the time
oh you guys took that just such the
wrong way
okay that should be fine there's another
way let's just go buy it
uh
is undead parish
what i'm thinking of
let's find out
left of the hydra where you killed the
golden golden golem
yeah we can't do that yet though without
doing something else
[Music]
let's just do this
well you need it
okay
where is this thing
pressed open sealed door in the heart of
the forest is this the one
yep
off we go
off we go wait can i upgrade
potential
what
no i still need one more twinkle tip
one more twinkle tip
[Music]
sorry is reading chat because you guys
get mad at me when i don't read every
single bit of wording that you say
[Applause]
yeah i know cypher we're gonna go kill
sif first
oh dude another thing about eldon ring
what is up with the uh
what are what are the upgrades called
i'm already forgetting because i i'm
back to tight knight
what are the upgrades called
anyway why are the the smithing stones
why are the sombers so much easier to
find
then
all the other [ __ ] smithing stones
you need
like it is so annoying to get all of
those regular smithing stones you need
it takes forever
you never find enough like you better
pick one weapon or you're never gonna
get enough smithing stones to upgrade
two normal weapons
you know
oh wait i wonder if this glitch still
works
yep
we answered that question
yeah you can get 10 somber in less than
an hour but regular
i don't know
because it's better
how is that better
the [ __ ]
awesome
i was mid-roll
i'm cheesing them
hello hey there we go
all your deaths sir thank you
wait did that one not fall no they did
okay good
do the outdated mechanics bother you
when playing these older games no that
actually feels good still the
the controls in this game feel great
what is that
is that a dude
hey it's spider shield guy i know you
from dark souls 3.
big dick discrimination
oh you guys took that the wrong way does
that not make sense though like
sometimes you don't want to do
what's a better way to put it all of the
required work
for that really cool big thing
right
is that better
now we're gonna do dark souls 2 after
this
mushroom boys
i always want a big pp all right i was
wrong never mind
hello shroomy boys
lead me to your leader
never mind
that's okay
i should have kindled that last bonfire
is that where sif is
hi taranator how are you
seem very knowledgeable
okay
y'all can shut your mouth
prepare to cry
i'm killing the dog
you think
sif is a male or a female probably a
male
sif sounds like a male named
sam
do the dlc first
you guys are leading me all over the
place
you attack so fast
that's an attack
good boy
okay
not going well
oh this is really not going well at all
okay
holy [ __ ]
he bonks me
i'm learning
learning
rip sif
eps in the chat for the good boy
he was a good boy
a very very good boy
and now he's dead
the hornet ring
am i blind boost critical attacks
you know all right that's okay i don't
really care at all
f for [ __ ] that dog no syphilis good boy
so let's say we go kill artorias first
and come back here
what doesn't he like get sad
or something
because we have artorius's soul or
whatever
i remember seeing that somewhere
it's behind the building with the stairs
there's so many buildings with stairs
he remembers you
me
i'm not his good boy
what the heck is this thing
what is this
it's the cat
why is the cat like this
[Music]
what is happening
i need to leave
run
run boys
yep the rune bears in the miss wood
definitely the hardest
in elder ring
in the dlc you go past and meet young
sip
oh
really
would have been cool
bone out
no
i don't want to waste a boner
because i'm like right here
okay peter griffin
behind this building
what the
okay
is it not so that thou art knew
thou fared well to find me but cometh
the not for the grave of saratoras
my advice true
forget this
the legend of artorias are none but a
fabrication
traversing the dark
what do i say
this cat looks so sus
i'm i'm talking to the cat right now
ruler shut the [ __ ] up
i have no idea what this cat just said
no
okay
a result most heathen-ish and gross
then there is nothing more to say about
this tedious reckoning
begun from here
pernicious katie
what did this cat just talk about
what a weird cat
i swear there was a cat like that in
dark souls 2
like in the main area
i don't remember
okay
um
what should we level like i feel like
her hp is pretty decent but it could be
a bit higher
yeah hp
yeah is it the same cat
excuse me
um do i want to kindle these
should we go kill the moonlight
butterfly
moonlight
bucket worst boss fight in the souls
series
for one of the worst
i'm on day three of your elden ring walk
through and after that i will be playing
dark souls 3 in bloodborne i see you
again i hope
sounds good
thanks for watching it
wow they look so big and so tough and
i'm one-shotting them
oh i like that armor
that armor is cool
i'm gonna start upping my uh
is it stamina that increases my equip
load
or endurance or whatever
all right murder the butterfly
[Music]
come down here let me murder you now
oh god
ow
[Music]
[Music]
now oh this fight sucks
it's just poop
thank
the lord that didn't take
at least the music's good
can all agree on that we pretty much
said that for every fight in the game
music's good
that's hall bird dude no kidding
i got super lucky
it's another andre
watch tower basement key and a divine
ember and a homeward boner
i'm going to use that homeward boner not
waste my time walking all the way back
up
bop boop
the boss looks kind of dumb
i mean yeah
pretty normal looking dark souls boss
has there ever been another butterfly in
the entire series
no
do you know gargoyles or [ __ ] i thought
they're cool
oh yeah we gotta put on the droop
and let me get back to uh andre though
melania
if you guys rated it on a tier list
what is uh what's melania
like f being terrible
and then like the typical s being the
best a b c
d
f
what would you rate melania
a six yeah that's not that's not it
malacath was way [ __ ] easier than
melania
at least for me
depends on your build i'm sure
let's start using this
s plus plus
f for the rot
the rod wasn't even bad
[Music]
i'd give melania a b
solid b
my i've seen one of those before oh my
bad it's the ember of a divine
blacksmith
might you consider leaving that with me
here's another question what would you
rate the height the halogen tree the
whole area what would you rate it
well
thanks for that
you've made a fine decision
you soon shall see
repair gear there's nothing wrong with
my gear
though
[Music]
i'll do it though [ __ ] it
learn gesture hurrah
an s d
five out of ten
don't get yourself killed see either of
us want to see i give the whole area b
plus millennia the whole area is just
reused
assets from the rest of the game except
for millennia
i like melania's moveset except for one
and you know what i'm talking about
that one move is total [ __ ]
[Music]
here
i think i kindled this one
i did
okay um let's level up endurance
we're gonna need to do that
where um where can i buy twinkle tits
let's try on that armor too that arm is
really cool elite night
yeah this looks sick
okay i'm not i'm like mid rolling
like alight
let's get something a little bit lighter
[Music]
a little bit lighter
because i like normal rolling
let's do black leather for now
that's fine
oh i'm just gonna keep upgrading i don't
i don't like rolling like that i hate it
actually
[Music]
to do oh my god
dude
i i will say the menuing i i miss it
in uh in elden ring
the
menuing yeah there we go
very good
the giant blacksmith sells twinkle tits
okay
[Music]
got it
how do you dodge that move waterfowl
you don't
not the first part of it
okay what were we doing
why did we kill
did i even get what i needed from sif
i think the music in elden ring is okay
compared to the other games
[Music]
god skin duo sound or yeah the god skin
music really stands out to me there's a
lot of good music in the elven ring
so i can go and kill the four kings now
yeah bloodhound step is how you dodge it
i don't remember
[Music]
okay
[Music]
godfrey song is cool
yeah i made a whole video on that j-dog
[Music]
if you wear the ring the covenant of
artorias
[Music]
oh i have to wear the ring
[Music]
interesting
i hate that you can't
teleport to every single uh
bonfire
it can only teleport to some
which one do i want to go to
hold on let me put on the ring we're
talking about before we continue
i'm gonna have to take this one off
aren't i
reverse the abyss
[Music]
it breaks when i remove it though
[Music]
so i guess i should just remove this for
now
right
fire length and go to the valley of the
drakes
yeah that's such a long walk there
though bro
yesterday you said it'd be better if
teleportation wasn't a thing where did i
[ __ ] say that
[Music]
all right we're fine
not rolling as fast as i would like but
we're gonna live with it
all right
[ __ ] it dude
i didn't have to do any elden ring lure
hunting god that [ __ ] was hard to piece
together
i
i have gotten to a point with the lauren
elden ring
that
i somewhat
am starting to dislike it
i really am
it's cool don't get me wrong but i can't
make sense of it
i think it's confusing for the sake of
being confusing
[Music]
yep we're going to the four kings
we got the ring
yeah i miss jumping too
okay let's not say the r word in the
chat please
do you think elven ring is overrated no
i don't think it's a masterpiece though
piccolo is a child he's eternal like
that's his thing he has
he's stuck in eternal youth
oh god guys this is gonna suck
i'm just gonna have to run huh
all right
let's get it
now
oh i love it all
right
run run run
run run run run run
and dodge
oh there's a ladder right there i kick
down we got to remember that if i die
here
i forgot about the ladder that's a big
shortcut actually
it's
massive
do we take the jump
[ __ ] it
i'm a gamer
don't ever get it mistaken
i thought i died
please let me be
how do i get back up
i don't need to get back up
understood
yeah i think moog just needs them to be
the vessel yeah can i just jump straight
down
[ __ ] it
[Music]
the obvious
oh okay
i'm scared
um
why is their health absurd
oh i'm killing one at a time
i love the hitbox here
okay
okay
okay
is there only four of them
considering they're the four kings
okay
good
good good good
what's happening okay
i'm still scared
what is he doing
what is that
it's still following
what the heck
what is he doing
this seems so insanely unfair
i tried to roll dude
what
what is he doing
i'm just confused now
this hitbox is so dumb
i'm dead
i'm not a fan of this fight at all
what is this [ __ ]
what
what
my
my sword just went directly through him
twice
did my sword not go directly through him
two times
[Music]
bruh
dang it
[Music]
you had this but you panicked
no it wasn't the fact that my sword went
through him two times
right
no i panicked
thank you stan
true
true
now we gotta run all the way back
right also the hitbox lingers like it's
dark souls 2.
i remember metal telling me that her
least favorite boston's entire game is
the four kings
yeah it's it's hard to measure distance
because there's no depth of field it's
just a
black background
everyone's attacks go through them when
you roll
why does it let me attack them that
doesn't even make sense
if i can't do damage while rolling why
does it let me attack
like the animation of doing so
okay we remember the latter though this
time yeah
i don't know how to get on the ladder
but we're gonna figure it out
is it over here
no
mimicrab attack so horrifying
i don't know
i'm gonna have to play dark souls 2
again to remember
i just remember not liking the hitboxes
hey there it is
found it
yes drop well look at that
look at that
where's the fp bar don't have one
yum yum
yum yum
fp is silly
wait what if i hit one of the sides okay
we didn't good good
excellent
[Music]
okay we got this this time right guys
okay my shit's actually all the way over
there really
howie
i can't tell how far away he is
i'm making the leap i'm making the run
go baby
okay
that's fine i think i'm far enough away
excellent
the left roll seems to be good
good stuff okay there's another one
yeah we're just gonna do that again huh
okay
that's dumb
what
where's their hand
who grabbed me
i just tried to kill him
what the [ __ ]
let me lock on please
leave me alone other
one i need to heal
are there [ __ ] three of them
oh my god this is so bad
i swear to god
wait the grab comes out of nowhere
what is that
um
[Music]
i didn't have to fight four of them last
time i tried that
just saying
i have a question when i'm in the abyss
can i take off the ring and put the
poise one back on
[Music]
no
all right time to go to face tank it
should have thrown the axe
[Music]
god
did you not see me just put on the
heaviest set of armor i have
before you said where the heaviest set
of armor
you have
[Music]
forehead
somebody's salty
does anyone get the vibe that robert
stratton is just like you just seem like
you sell insurance
robert stratton health insurance
selling boats would be my second guess
so
voicing what's the heck was that
calling me on [ __ ] you called me salty
[ __ ] you
this orgasmic sounds yeah
all right see how this does
the run back's not that bad
i still hate it though
should i even roll
or just heal through it and just face
tank it
all right
we'll do that for each one
no no no no no no
come here
i'll [ __ ] you
just gonna get through it okay
that's fine
[Music]
bum
are you spawn so far away
we're running for me
that was dumb
okay this is much better
considering there's not four of them
right now
[Music]
marry your forehead
thank you
why did that hurt more
are you kidding
oh my god i'm gonna get trolled here
aren't i
i got i just got to go at it huh
just keep going
sick
i love it
that was this horrible rng
son of a [ __ ]
this fight sucks
that was really bad luck
yeah i got the strategy
you want a hug
i don't want to hug from a guy that
sells boats
probably all salty
i didn't get good yet
yet
it is just a dps check
the dps is insane though
like the needed dps
yeah we are really running here
really
really moving
do i have havel's armor i don't think so
i didn't see it i would have put it on
if i had it
you need more dps i don't think so
we were doing fine we just got horrible
rng with like the third one there
the [ __ ]
the points to have the armor on during
the fight
did i go the wrong [ __ ] way
like where the hell am i right now
where the [ __ ] i am
hell am i doing back here
oh i am just
upset
no way a ghost can kick me off a ladder
right yeah okay good
okay
not distracted
i lost a free boat ride oh no
a water car
oh no
i lost my oh i can't ride in a water car
now
dang it
i hate it here
okay
[ __ ] the runes [ __ ] the souls i mean
come here you bastard
i hate you
i hate you and your grandma and
all of it
hopefully i don't die
this boss sucks
this boss is bad
i'm not doing it yet
i'm getting upset
and i don't want to get upset
i'm gonna do it later
[ __ ] it
where's havel's ring
i don't want to do it yet
it's making me mad
and now i don't want to be mad
what do we need to get to the dlc
we need
to go to that one place that i can't
remember the name of
no the tanking would work if i did a
little bit more damage
[Music]
yeah where's the archives is that uh
okay i remember now i'm remembering now
okay
got it
we couldn't go there earlier but now we
can
thank
you go to gundyr
maybe in a couple weeks
i member
i don't know what you mean by souls like
i've seen you ask that question three
times
kill the first blue golem you see
i
what the hell is that
i have to stick this up his butt
that hurt a lot
oh i like it
why can't i
hit his butthole
oh well
this butthole is protected
[Music]
oh my god
yo what up
like [ __ ] me
please chat
just smell it
yeah his butthole is protected
let me like this [ __ ] up
[Music]
listen i say some things by accident
right
why is this here
i'm going on this thing
was it really an accident
that i said [ __ ] me please chat just
smell it
no it wasn't an accident
yeah this does look like the academy
i am
having a difficult time
with the game right now
it's kind of kicking my ass
my god
okay i killed the golem i have the
pendant
should i continue through duke's archive
or to stay here
or or leave go to the dlc
why don't you use your shield because i
use it for stamina
go to the eternal city shut the [ __ ] up
robert
kill seath dlc
dlc
continue
leave i guess it doesn't matter
i'm gonna leave since i redid the thing
warping out of here
i'm gonna go
ah
[ __ ]
trying to think of where to go
it's so hard to remember where what
paths lead to what
what is the depths that's way down
yonder
you won't be able to do dlc i'm staying
here
i think y'all are trying to trick me
we're just gonna do this area
let me continue through here
ow
[Applause]
okay
all these people again
oh
feel free to do you want streamer
thank you
i like that answer a lot
oh
yes i am
how about in public video games are
starting to melt you take a break
what
i don't like this
just did not like that area at all
oh they're all stronger because of the
[ __ ] wizard dude
bye bye
the heck is messaging me
check the site i'm not clicking on any
link you send me
oh god
okay
ow
not you you better not be linking
anything in my chat
you're already on the fence
yeah twinkle twin
yes we can upgrade
nice
huh
hey
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what
was i supposed to die
[Music]
oh i'm kindling this one in particular
if possible oh yeah
oh we are kindling this one 100
you were supposed to die there yeah that
did not look possible
[Music]
yeah i do not remember fighting him
there
interesting
can't believe you couldn't kill an
invincible boss shake my head
that sounds about right
i like the skill
i am so sorry chat
i will do better next time for all of
you
[Music]
owie
payne
hi maddie what's duke skip
wait i can't get out of here
you
let me out
let me out now
now i say
i got a warp
what do i do
lunch
how would that help
i want spaghetti
you didn't get spaghetti sauce
i love the rag doll kill snake
how do i kill the snake
punch him through the bars
he had two health
okay
oh
i hate snakes
[Music]
what is going on
[Music]
oh
[Music]
why are they running away
[Music]
why are there clock sounds
am i on a timer of some kind right now
are they running away because uh they're
scared of these people
[Music]
i'm scared of them too
not as scared of him now
okay
i'm going right down to him i ain't a
[ __ ]
i ain't scared
i don't get scared
whenever i scream like a little girl
it's for more power
like a tennis player
[Music]
[Music]
why do i need an extra key
[Music]
what
[Music]
this is weird
[Music]
like like like
hello
[Music]
[Music]
okay
do i do something with this
hey glenn
oops
[Music]
okay those guys are kind of dumb
[Music]
they're non-hostile
why wouldn't i
how would i know not to kill them
what the [ __ ]
dude
are all of are all of from software's
games
weirdly inconsistent throughout the game
what happens if i go up
now you miss them permanently how would
i know that
yo
you're in my mom's car
okay i'm gonna go this way i guess
or not why is this here
secret door
okay we're gonna go back
that's why elden ring wasn't a big deal
for me at the end
yeah i'm not seeing like a giant spike
elden ring has a huge spike
like a massive
insane
clearly unbalanced spike
so they don't respond okay
this place is scary
i feel like struggles only matter
for certain builds
in elden ring more than any other game i
feel like in dark souls you could have
any build and like get through the game
but like as easily as others
what's wrong with the game becoming
harder it doesn't become harder it
becomes
like the bosses do an insane amount of
damage no matter how many points you put
into health
so it's like your build didn't even
matter toward the end
and it felt unfinished
they didn't finish the areas
archive tower giant door key
okay
where's the giant door
should i pull this
does it play me music
no okay
do i go down to these four heads
unless you want your eardrums to explode
i don't
i don't want that
my assumption is that they won't attack
me and i'm wrong
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right didn't even have to do that
sick
are the big doors all the way up back up
top
i'm assuming
there's some really unfinished areas
later in dark souls 1.
i'm sure there are like in all of their
games right like they they have to have
like uh
it's just so clear in elden ring that
the
consecrated snow fields are not finished
at all
uh
the mountaintops of the giants are not
finished
and then it's like okay so how do we
play it off that these areas aren't
finished let's put it into the lore
yeah
there's glowing
translucent trees for some reason
you know
ah that's the door we like these doors
are not giant
you mean by not finished compared to the
rest of the game the quality goes
straight down like this these
surrounding areas just are not done
it's a clear lack of content there
compared to the rest of the game
oh cool
stop dancing
your dance moves are bad
going back to the start
that's what i'm saying
snowfield mountaintop of the giants are
clearly not done
what's this dude
isn't it supposed to be empty oh [ __ ]
harry potter that's what they'll tell
you
let's just ride it into the lower that
we didn't finish these areas
because they're just like barren it's
like a blank canvas
with some of the painting done
you know
maybe i'm being too hard on it
i've probably just played elden ring too
much
like i've played elden ring like uh a
hundred hours a month since it came out
it's a lot
i'm probably being too critical
now i'm only being critical because i
love the game if i didn't give a [ __ ]
about the game i just wouldn't say
anything you know
it's clearly not done though
another twinkle tit okay
i likey
i likey
okay i think uh well actually i can go
this way
where is your drip
i don't got no drip yet i'm working on
it
how do you guys feel about man buns
yeah this is dark souls one
my hair has gotten so long but i haven't
pulled up into my hat
like a bun
i just jump down there
i guess i'm a soy boy
stop it wizard
okay chain is out we're good
strong magic shield
sounds soy not going to use it
they require a specific face structure
to work
okie dokie then
got the ragdoll
hold vain i don't know what that is
some harry potter [ __ ] dog
okay
should i go down here
i don't think i've been over here
there
oh hello
[Music]
yep my drip is currently gone but only
for a moment
ow
oh is this just a massive shortcut
no
oh
give me that [ __ ]
uh-huh
is this called anything no i can't warp
here if i wanted to i want to go level
or upgrade my weapon
we're going to be playing a lot of games
here soon
um
there's a horror game called madison
coming out that i want to play on stream
or not on stream but maybe make a video
series out of
and then uh
straight
i do not want to wear that no sure
we're gonna have you guys heard a stray
the where he plays a cat
i want to play that
oh weird that there were no sound
effects to that but that's okay
bang
hey
yeah straight looks really cool i'm
excited for that one
he plays like a cat in a robot world
that sounds awesome
chest above okay thank you cj
i will go take a look
um
didn't i already get it there's one
right there oh sorry
i missed this one
archive john didn't already have oh
that's the cell key not giant door
okay
whoops
um
chat where have you taken me
where am i
i'm scared
yeah i'll either stream it or make a
video series out of it
probably a video series for stray
still debating on madison though
because i like horror games a lot
four games would probably be fun to
stream
if we want to do this soul series it's
gonna it's gonna take up all our time
like okay i i just you know like maybe
i'm being a bit too uh
a bit too
maybe i'm being a bit
critical today but and i know this game
is from 2000 what 11.
does this area not seem
finished
i see a lot of grass and some really
contrasting
gargoyles
grouped up in a corner over there
that it seems not finished right
maybe i'm just being a dick you know
that's a possibility
yeah it doesn't look good
like this right here that that does does
that this doesn't look good you know
doesn't look done
that's okay
you know
some areas are gonna be more done than
others
oh god
okay sorry i thought that was a dragon
eye up there
she's unfinished
yeah
i like the move sets for these gargoyles
or these uh golems though it's cool
leave her alone
okay i'm sorry
you could remove the whole area someone
asked about the quarry earlier uh no i
feel like that ship is sailed like if i
wanna make a video series or stream a
game it's gotta be when it releases
so
whenever stray comes out i'll either
make a video series or i'll stream it
uh
[Music]
or
uh or madison as well i'm actually
really excited for madison
it reminds me of visage
why don't you make a game yeah because i
can't criticize
something unless i'm capable of making
it myself right
as everyone say demon souls is the
easiest i wouldn't know i haven't played
demon souls i've only watched it
well this doesn't seem safe
uh
yo what the [ __ ] is that
okay
um
what the
i could not have panicked harder
it i just got scared
it just i just got scared that's all
that's all that happened there i just
panicked
that was just pure
panic
nothing more
nothing less
my god
i hate it when people use that argument
no i know you're [ __ ] with me i i i
get it now dude
i get it
well you're not from software
you can't be critical because you're not
from software you can't be credible you
think something you love
and like i was saying if i didn't give a
[ __ ] about these games i wouldn't
criticize it at all
i just wouldn't play them
you know i'm saying
like the fact i'm [ __ ] playing it
tells a lot
ding
you guys just slide off the side that'd
be sick
okay
you know what lorenzo everyone put
hearts in the chat for lorenzo because
he's back now
and we like it when he's here
and i'm glad you're back
is it telling me that there's a secret
passage
like i can stand here
that's just scary looking
okay
scared
wait are these moonlight butterflies
like for real for real
i'm upset at myself
okay gonna have to trust the snow
this was an elden ring
yes they are lorenzo
why is this one so strong
i don't like it
i'm gonna fight it though
oh i love getting hit yes
i'm gonna heal right in front of your
face
i shouldn't have done that
nice totally missed
okay good another moonlight
little [ __ ]
so i just can't hurt them yeah
is that what i'm learning there
time to run
what the
why did it
[Music]
oh my god why did i just slide off so
hardcore there
you know syndrome is voiced by quindale
dingle
twink these nuts dude
ice
start getting good
okay aj
i'm sorry
i'll do better for you mommy
he buttered the floors of the area
oh my god
it's mogan time
you missed the chest five times i
literally went up to the chest
that you told me to get
and then i said thanks cj
now i wish i didn't because you seem
like an [ __ ]
i am amazing aren't i metal
there's another one you can tell me that
you have to be a dick about it
oh i'm slipping and sliding
did the other gold one slip off with me
nice
okay where
where
where do i go
i'm scared of sliding
okay i see it
i see it
um
what do i do
good good good
is this even where i want to be
okay
i'll go a bit faster
why do i feel like i'm not going
anywhere
this is back where we started
i guess that's just a way to get back up
here
okay
go down not up i didn't see it down
i didn't see it okay
is there a down
oh okay
okay
i'm scared
okay
i did not like that
not one bittle tittle
okay what the [ __ ] man
are those clams
i don't like the way they move
now we
okay
they're gonna follow me into the boss
arena not if i murder them
stop talking
why is there difficulty increased
[Applause]
so fast
[Applause]
this is not what we wanted before the
boss fight
they dropped twinkies
they didn't drop twinkies what is this
where are we
that looks nice
something totally won't happen okay
why wouldn't i be able to see the drop
thing
oh it's [ __ ] see
go go go
why did i do no damage
what did i do
[Music]
okay i'm hurting him
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't those hurt me
those dead
is this the most back tail no
yeah i want to cut off his tail
[Music]
oh come on bro
he's [ __ ] glitching out man
what the [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ]
you just started spazzing out man
what the hell
he started glitching around
no health left man
it's an int weapon you don't need it
to uh chop off his tail that's what i
get
all right
we'll get back there pretty quick
goodness
just pure pain one more hit on that boss
and he's dead
one more hit
and then he uses all of his stuff
to make sure i die before i can do that
man
right
why
why
how
it just pushed me off for no reason
what the [ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate you cj
going back over here
kindling it
you were near the edge so you slid
i'm just gonna
you know i thought i was following the
path just fine
the item
you know
nope
nope
i'm sure the mimic drop drop something
i'm sure it does
yeah that's great
that's great man
and look at that nice shiny glowing item
right there
i hope it
cringes your brain and you get a
headache that i didn't pick it up
foreign
he fell
the kindle all the way up with 20 flash
that's way too many flash
i thought i died
are you bored no
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ] plans
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
a couple of floppy wieners
okay i feel better now
i needed to not talk
i need to beat the boss
i feel good now though
[Music]
oh i know
i deserve the trolling
i
deserve it
you killed the father of sorcery good
good
i'm glad
is that all i needed here
i i under you guys feed on me struggling
i understand that
that's
fine let's go upgrade
this [ __ ] i've been streaming for two
and a half hours already
time flies when you're having fun
[Music]
andre help me well hello again
i'm doing amazing buddy
[Music]
two
three more twinkle titties
don't get yourself killed of course i'm
having fun neither of us want to see you
go hollow
jake feeds on the blood of his idiots
now where do we go
[Music]
catacombs
let's start the catacombs
[Music]
that caught me off guard that was the
point
[Music]
nido's too strong for now
really
i feel like that's not true
tip metal enchilada
metal went to the store to get spaghetti
sauce
you got to get the presto
you got to get the meat presto
by the way
veto's a joke
need light
what are you saying
[Music]
why are you in the bathroom almost
throwing up
what happened
i'm confused
i couldn't hear everything you said
his area is the hardest part in the uh
the boss is easy let's let's try it
let's give it a try
i sleep like that
[ __ ]
bless me
i think we're gonna be fine
we gotta kill pinwheel
right guys
hardest boss in the game
because i can only play for another 30
minutes
i'm trying to limit my stream time to
about three hours a day
[Applause]
i'm trying not to puke in the hallway
and i finally got to the bathroom and i
didn't have to puke anymore why did you
have to puke what happened
just from drinking yesterday
ooh binoculars
you need a holy weapon no i don't
that is
not true
is this not how you get there am i
tripping balls
am i tripping nut sacks right now
ah here we go
i do not need a holder
we're gonna be fine
ow
oh god
get owned
you suck
okay
this place is scary
hey bonfire
it's lit
excellent
he has mobs in the boss room that only
died a holy
it won't matter because i'll [ __ ]
kill him
with this weapon
did i do what i need to do here
i think so
let me go up the hill
pretty
what a crazy attack
ow
dude rick likes getting hit by
everything
he loves it dude
get back
here
stop
stop running
come here
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
that just wasn't worth it at all was it
what's going on over here
i'm just scared now
what am i not scared pvh
guys
i need
everything to stop happening
i need all this to stop
stop
[Music]
oh i'm having a rough go of it
oh my god i'm having a rough go of it
bro
it just wouldn't stop
they wouldn't stop
they just kept doing it man
all right we're gonna be fine
oh
those moans are really hot thank you
i know i'm hot you don't gotta tell me
is this fair
is life fair
no
so quit your bitching
life ain't fair
[Applause]
time to get the [ __ ] over it
oh
[ __ ] your boat
i bet your boats are stupid
and overpriced
for a water car
how do i get over there
oh i see
did that statue just stab me
[Applause]
worse
this place is a troll right
like i'm getting trolled yeah
what did i even unlock
[Music]
i did
okay
oh good you can salt these nuts
chant
insult these nuts
i got lost
i'm using my shield for stamina i guess
that would actually be helpful right
there it is
okay
that guy's dead
okay well they're alive so that means
i'll live too right
i love green titties
what
all right we made it
oh god
why is he why is his voice like that
what the
you weren't in the cut
[Music]
scene yeah why is his voice so crisp
like he's using a blue yeti
okay
[Music]
i can't afraid yet
what was that about don't be coming
around here without a good reason
okay i'm sorry
we just burst a hole in the wall just to
have me leave
i hate this
i
i just
i just
like come on man come on man
come on dude
what
oh
that was just
awful
tunnel to the right
leave me alone
stupid wheelies
the [ __ ] in here
oh my god
whoa creepy
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's [ __ ] pinwheel
oh my god it's pinwheel
okay
[Music]
what a joke of a boss what the heck was
that
that was stupid
i've been stuck on this boss since 2011.
oh boy
it's so dark oh my god
do i have a torch
are those eyeballs
yep
okay good
this is fine
we're fine
oh stop sliding me please ah
okay
mommy
mommy
please leave me alone
please
i don't like this
i'm scared
chat
chat
i'm scared
okay
oh god
okay
i think that's a ladder
is that a bonfire
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
we made it
we [ __ ] made it
holy [ __ ]
wow
for a guy that's died
many a time to fall damage
that's the place where i don't
i would say that's impressive wouldn't
you
i'm impressed with
the
myself
is that
okay
ladies and gentlemen
i think that's a perfect place for us to
stop for today
because
i don't think we're gonna make much more
progression until tomorrow
oh boys
boys and girls
thank you for being here
what an eventful day
all right maybe we just maybe we just
banned robert i just you can't say [ __ ]
like that you've also said the r word
today
gonna get me banned
anyway
people
i'm out of here
i hope you all have a great rest of your
day
check out the links in the description
you'll probably see me fall tomorrow i'm
gonna i'm definitely gonna die to fall
damage tomorrow
trust me we had plenty of it today
we had plenty of it the day before and
the day before that
yeah you guys just can't say the g word
you just can't do that
four heads
anyway
i'm
out have a great day i'm gonna get some
food i ate before stream but i'm hungry
again i don't want to see what i can eat
uh i'm gonna go play with my dog
i might go play some golf too i didn't
get to do that this morning
100 degrees outside though so yeah
we'll be back sometime tomorrow uh
around the same time as we started today
so
minus three hours from the time that it
is for you right now and that's when
i'll probably start
um let me just think
i don't got anything else to say this is
a perfect stopping point right here i
think so
yeah one enchilada was not enough to eat
today so
i'm gonna go get some more but thanks
for all the support guys i appreciate
you
and i will see you